joining us here on the rich eisen show
on the mercedes-benz vans phone line
fresh off that dub against the cleveland
browns they're now the sixth seed in the
afc playoffs
eight weeks into the season from the
pittsburgh steelers cameron hayward how
are you
sir i'm good mr eisenhower i'm doing
better for talking to you no question
about that i i appreciate you calling
into this show what's uh what's been
going on around your parts that things
look a lot better this past month than
the first in the nfl cameron man you
know i think uh
you know a little bit of luck
a lot of practice
uh guys getting healthy you know i know
we've had some injuries early on whether
it was tj or alex high smith
chase claypool
um but you know we're finding our stride
and
hopefully it can continue from here on
out well i mean what was it like
going through that first month of the
season um
for you and that team and and and what
you've been able to
work through that adversity for you
cameron
you know it was a little bit tough um
with the injuries uh you know they play
a factor in every game and you know
they're going to happen throughout the
season
um but you know with that younger guys
got a chance to step up early
um and now that's provided depth for us
now and we got to continue to grow with
that but
it's just about staying the course you
know um understanding that you know
you're not gonna win every game all the
time but uh what can we learn from it
how can we get better because of it well
and then the other side of the ball
cameron um your rookie running back your
rookie teammate naji harris appears to
be one of those bonafide to use the
phrase grown-ass men running the
football in the nfl what's it been like
to have a front row seat watching his
blossoming at that position so far for
you man well the cool thing is uh you
know during training camp um you know
you blow up a play and you think it's
where tackles are lost um but naji's
always fighting for extra yards and
they'll shake you out of the hole
and i remember getting pretty annoyed
i'm pretty pissed off with myself that
uh he was getting out of it um now that
i'm looking back i'm glad he's doing it
now so
glad he's on my sideline yeah how does
that affect the team as a whole though
that style of play and success at it um
how does that
affect all 53 on the roster for you when
he's converting first downs i think it's
huge and always falling forward um you
know you get into a game back and forth
where you know first
defense to really you know let down uh
is going to pay for it um and you know
over a game you just see them start to
erode at teams and
we're needing every bit of it uh you
know the best type of defense is the
defense on the sideline and when nazi's
converting first down after first down
uh we love that type of ball
well and certainly too it allows uh ben
to stay more clean you know it it it
balances the offense it definitely keeps
the defense
from pinning you know their ears back
and going to hunt the quarterback and it
also
keeps you off the field you know it
affects everything the way that i'm
seeing it
camera of course yeah you know i think
it's uh you know to have a monster like
that and to him balance out our passing
attack um and then still be uh
a contributor in the passing attack um
and it helps out all folds and
um you know i i thank kevin colbert
every day for making that pick
well
cameron hayward here on the rich eisen
show you're born in pittsburgh pa
obviously uh well it's it's obvious to
me but others may not know you're a
buckeye what's it like to win as a
steeler in cleveland ohio what is that
feeling like for you oh um well my
wife's from cleveland
um go back i always go back to the
stomach grounds and um you know i i i
i've always had a fun times in ohio as a
college player um and i became an enemy
uh 11 years ago but
uh you know you always want to get the
bragging rights because
you feel like that's your hometown and
you know me and ben both have that
problem yeah i know and next up for you
is justin fields so i guess the old
alumni association's gonna have to go
out the window for monday night football
coming up correct yeah they might just a
little bit
okay i just want to make sure about all
that
how does it also affect the team did you
guys know that uh miles garrett showed
up uh as the grim reaper yesterday
coming to work did you see that with the
names of all the quarterbacks he's
bagged on on his cape did that i just i
didn't take a look at it before the game
i saw it after um
you know it was cute
okay cute um
to piss you off i mean does it piss the
steelers no no i'm just kidding
no uh you know to each his own um you
know that was a cool outfit uh
he stacked a lot of quarterbacks i'll
say that okay cameron hey hayward of the
pittsburgh steelers two-time all-pro
defensive tackle right here on the rich
eisen show what's it like to play next
to tj watt you got a good story for me
on on on your teammate sitting next to
you man tj is competitive as hell um in
everything that we do um
and you know he always gives himself a
chance
whether it's in a card game where he
shouldn't be playing at all
um to
you know he
this is what this is how demented his
mind is
he played quarterback in high school and
he swears to this day that he could go
back in college and lead
some team to a national championship and
i'm like tj like
you got you got two bum knees in college
to begin with and now you're telling me
you can play quarterback so
um you know he's competitive and thinks
he thinks outworldly he plays outwardly
um but you know we're glad we have him
all right let's scrub back a few seconds
he thinks what what does he think
tj thinks he can
he thinks he can go back and play
um
quarterback at a college program and
take him to a national champion
like okay like a power five like a like
tj watt thinks he could play quarterback
if he can go back into college and lead
a team to a national championship that's
what he thinks yeah he has said those
words out of his mouth and it goes in
your ear another human being like that's
actually happened is what you're saying
yeah first of all it started off at high
school he could go to any texas program
and take the worst team and take them to
the their high school championship we
were like tj and then he then he went to
college and we're like tj now you're
just you're gassing it up so
you know
it's pretty it's pretty wild
well while we're on the subject of
talking a good game um
uh cameron hayward i got to ask you
about your coach and mike tomlin uh and
what he had to say about the rumor that
well that's not the the fact that he's
on the wish list for usc football for
their for their um head coaching vacancy
and his response is one of the greatest
responses i said it's up there in the
sound bite with you know the jim mora
playoffs or the denny green the bears
are who we thought they were like it's
up there with that this is our new
favorite drop here on the rich eisen
show go ahead never say never but never
that was incredible like that was truly
one of the most succinct five words to
to shut the the door on a rumor that
i've ever heard what was how did that
land in your locker room cameron hayward
you know
it it really didn't land in our locker
room but
you know me being an older player and
um knowing coach t
you know it just puts the rubber stamp
on it you know and it cements what he
does
um you know coach t is locked in and you
know he's not looking for a quick out
you know he he thinks he has the
greatest job and you know we know it
every single day he appreciates every
moment
so when you say it didn't land in the
locker room nobody was talking about it
nobody heard you hear what tomlin had to
say or did you hear that that that does
not come up when you're now now we we do
our own things where we like to screw
with coach steve whether it's you know
been wearing his ufc gloves during a
meeting
[Applause]
[Laughter]
wait a minute wait a minute
what happened what do you got
you know there's subtle things we do
here and there i think one time i think
we were going to play the ufc song
during our warm-up but i think that got
mixed pretty quick
who had the gumption to even think about
hitting play on on the the fight on
theme there
anybody was that you i can't round them
out you know that might get them in
trouble
but when you say it put the rubber stamp
on coach t and what he does what does he
do what does he do
he's consistent um and he challenges us
um and he comes to work
fully locked in uh for every single
player whether you're
the first player in or the last player
in you know um
just getting to know him over these
years you really do appreciate how
consistent he is in the message he
portrays to the team
okay and uh last one for you cameron
since you've been taking us inside um is
chris boswell's throwing career over
it better be
i have no more time for that
yes
you know he he said uh he he instagramed
out dressed up as a qb for halloween and
got spooked is what he
was what he instagrammed
so you're done with him for his coaching
for his quarterback career correct yeah
we don't even have a backup so yeah i
noticed
we all noticed
we all noticed that but i guess we can
all laugh about it now uh hey uh your
your brother's alma mater took care of
mine this weekend i just figured i'd
talk about the elephant in the room
right now sorry about that are you
really though cameron are you really i'm
i'm not you know because i'm not i'm
gonna try tonight you know
uh it was a big week for the haywards
uh we went 2-0 this week and we got to
keep going on until we play each other
well i mean uh that occurs when do you
think i guess collegiately your alma
mater he's going to be taking on your
school currently right now and for for
all the marbles it looks like right now
yeah i think it's uh a couple of weeks
last the week before michigan yes that's
correct right before thanksgiving okay
so do you
put your allegiance aside and what do
you what do you do
for that i say good luck and uh
hopefully you stay healthy um have a
good game but you're not winning this
game oh wow
okay
we found out what's thicker okay i got
it
i like it hey cameron uh appreciate the
time here let's do this more often i
greatly appreciate it it's a good chat
congrats on the w and let's talk down
the line
yes sir thank you you bet that's cameron
hayward of the pittsburgh steelers right
here on the rich eisen show ben wearing
his ufc gloves and who had the temerity
funny to say
let's
play the usc fight song and practice now
can i guess
sure sure okay it had to be a veteran
i'm gonna guess ben's the one who put
the kibosh on it
how about that
ben's the one like yeah
maybe we don't do this all right hold on
let me go there's enough there's a
that's so crazy
about playing fight on
they thought about playing fire right so
the only usc player on the roster yeah
uh tackle zach banner
yeah i don't think that is if you're
veteran
well he could be the one to provide the
uh the link
to the song yeah that's funny that's
funny oh my god well juju smith schuster
obviously
not with the team right he's a beloved
man who you can't how you can't stay
angry at juju for literally more than a
second yeah you can't but he's probably
not around the team right now i don't
know so you never know all right i guess
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here